[Music]
police say
that a husband
asked spell casters to hex his wife
before she disappeared
oh [ __ ] she actually disappeared she
actually disappeared is that a crime if
if it actually worked spellcasters is
not even a real class it's got to be
warlock black mage what is a spell
caster that's all of the above maybe
they don't have one they only have one
one skill they don't have they don't
have all the other ones they can't
teleport or like stop time they just do
spells they're doing the spell from like
a melee range or like a range range it
was from melee range what's melee range
like an intermediate range like right
here like i could punch you yeah
i thought it was like malaysia or
something melee
when you're in the military did you guys
learn cqc
maybe you played no it's not you don't
even know what that is dude you were in
the military
you know he has a syndrome this is what
cqc is but we do because we played metal
gear
you just saw those
tqcs i said yeah dude
bro he wasn't in the melee terry yeah
see wow thank you joe thank you i'm
coming around thank you bailey terry
look what you started anthony first of
all watch what you're going to finish
i don't know
i don't know where that came from let's
go uh so
maya
uh is her name she she went missing
from chula vista california which is
actually pretty close to san diego so i
know it's san diego isn't it yeah
yeah good good [ __ ] that's on the border
baby um she was planning her birthday
she just vanished all of a sudden
um because the spellcaster
that's what it was like
so he told the police that he casted
spells on her so first
before the police uncovered this right
they were just physically looking for
this woman who went missing right and so
they had search parties and they had
friends and family and colleagues and
people that she knew and they're all
looking for her right and they called
themselves team maya and they're going
all around san diego like chula vista
area the desert near the air they're
like going all the way as far as the
arizona border whoa yeah and they they
were focused on this area because the uh
the two had gone hiking there and larry
was familiar with the area local media
also followed the searches with the hope
that maya might be found months later
though
um they they kind of um
came to the
the conclusion that they weren't going
to find her alive months later whoa yeah
well you know you don't you don't want
to say that initially because there's
hope and stuff but i love a conclusion
man yeah
um
so
you know skipping down uh us a ways
uh they they they found out that maya
and larry had had some issues inside of
their marriage
and friends were indicating that these
troubles had gone on for a little while
and larry was taking some very unusual
approaches to try to avoid a divorce
such as
he contacted
spell casters
in an attempt to get his wife to stay in
the marriage initially
so there are people on the internet like
oh she wanted to
change her mind yeah there are people on
the internet you can pay them they'll
like make a spell that'll make a more
attractive or some [ __ ] right oh like on
fiverr or something like on fiverr yeah
i thought all you're supposed to do is
like kind of like jizz on your
fingertips and then put it on your neck
and then your wrist that's love potion
pheromones yeah i think when you're
already in the marriage
love potions don't work anymore oh [ __ ]
that's why you pheromones
that's why you had to go to fiverr
and you had to dude i love how fiber's
in the mix now dude well dude one-stop
shop man are they going to get in
trouble for this who's going to take
responsibility for it you can buy
spells and then they'll email you the
spell and you got to read the spell out
loud through the email cast a spell to
your you know or if you pay another five
bucks they might read it for you
and you go hey babe you gotta hear this
that's the gold premium abracadabra
that's the premium level yeah on fiverr
so let's fast forward to october 19th
2021. according to authorities the month
before maya disappeared larry was all of
a sudden getting increasingly panicked
the spells were not working
one message to a news spellcaster on
fiverr larry wrote please punish may
which is maya's like
nickname
okay and incapacitate her enough so she
can't leave the house it's time to take
the gloves off and let's do some real
casting [ __ ] that's what he says holy
[ __ ] so he went from
those text messages dude let's try to
magically keep her to now let's
let's feedbound her
so before he was spending like five mana
he was like this time
[Laughter]
that's what happened
it's crazy
that's 10x yeah
he spent 50 mana on this next spell
right we should so authority's gotta tap
his money to use a lot of ethers to
recover authorities um have announced
now that the last known call that she
made before
she went missing on the day that she
went missing the last phone call she
made
was to a divorce attorney oh [ __ ]
so the
so there the police are are now led to
believe that the spells did not work
does he get a police or linton police
they don't think the spells work yeah so
he should get a refund right he's
definitely going to be like i'm not
going to do the spells i'm just going to
kill her instead that's what this
article is about it's about how this guy
should get a refund from all you guys
if they emailed you the spell already
how do you get a refund if they already
emailed you you can't email the back
faulty service though you know what i
mean yeah it just didn't work it's like
it's like getting the coupon code
doesn't [ __ ] work you have to bring
the back the sacred scroll of proof aka
the receipt
yeah or at least just give me my money
back
either or i'll take
did they find her no
no
thanks for putting a dapper on the
[ __ ] story we're having so much fun
well i mean like the spell
so no they should get he should get his
money back and and more
because not only did they like his wife
back keep her
no not only did they fail at keeping her
around she completely disappeared
the spell backfired yeah oh [ __ ]
something you guys said the wrong
incantation i think that's what happened
like in the spell book the pages were
[ __ ] stuck together or some [ __ ]
maybe they're just like well
usually people want people to go away
so we just thought this was one of those
go away spells so we just did that on
accident he did a runaway spell and it
worked
i imagine the moment where he like wrote
this spell on his hand and then he came
over but his hand was sweaty like oh
[ __ ] what does that say
well they also think that maybe what
happened was the guys were using an old
spell because their inventory was full
so they actually couldn't have they were
carrying too many herbs
i have newts they couldn't put the new
spell in their inventory because their
inventory was already full they had to
go actually like offload their inventory
if they do that right the spellcasters
were right ready you're right that's
[ __ ] bunch of supply chain issues
nowadays yeah he sold him a [ __ ]
lemon for a spell like he's that [ __ ]
was salvaged
that's [ __ ] up dude he should have got
a new spell did she run away or she
she's missing i like to think she ran
away he was he was he's been arrested oh
so police think that he's involved but
they don't have a body yet and they have
basically traveled to an area they've
they've ruled like like they've
honed in to this one place right two and
a half hours from chula vista
a couple square miles is where they're
focusing on some camping locations that
they're both familiar with on the anza
breeze anza borrego desert or at the
glamous california sand dunes in
imperial county that place is dope and
they're looking all around that area but
there's so much land to look through
that's a lot of sand glamis is a lot of
that's just sand dunes and larry's not
saying [ __ ] so he just resists to refer
to my spellcaster i mean she hated this
dude so much that he that she just ran
away and disappeared
and she [ __ ] abracadabred herself she
hit her with one of these
i disappeared oh nice classic i killed
her you you think so but i like to play
[ __ ] i never saw any of that yeah
you think he killed him is that in there
it's not in here
yeah that's
not anywhere in here i think he loved
her so much that he killed her [ __ ]
i'm kidding he's like
if i can't have her no one can that's
what happens yeah yeah i mean given how
he went from like i'm gonna cast a spell
to keep her with me and then he's like i
need to cast a spell like let's
incapacitate what other things did he
try before he went to spellcast well i
think he went to the wrong psychics
how about communicate with her about
making her more attracted to you yeah
yeah that was an interesting thing
that's a lost cosmic singing telegram if
you could do that there'd be no single
wizards left yeah
that's true [ __ ] are you talking about i
don't know
what the [ __ ] you talking about
bart do you have anything to add to this
uh wizard stuff no or mana or anything
yeah you're suspiciously quiet yeah you
didn't say anything about mono you know
where were you druid
you don't know what any of the stuff is
you know what a mage is yeah you didn't
have any of that [ __ ] in the military
kind of what kind of wars are we playing
out there oh you're in the video games
dude he's one of the dwarves or whatever
you have a military guy yeah what kind
of support do you get in the military
you gotta have at least one wizard in
your troops one at least are you guys
making fun of me mages
hey that was good
i just thought what he said man that's
cool yeah wait so did you ever play
dungeons dragons or anything that kind
of [ __ ]
no you're too busy kicking those kids
ass
flipping their boards over ripping them
their cards up no i played it
you rolled to zero
that was it called uh dolls were like
big two that's a little so it does
that's what we play yeah
yeah asians don't have things like mana
and spell casters i don't matter for
magic the gathering you probably beat
those kids up huh nope i was like i was
those kids
no they're my friends they're my friends
if asians don't have no mana or nothing
like that how come this guy's busting a
[ __ ] gut about it he's never dude
he's uh he's hispanic oh yeah oh my god
cool i thought he's cupid latinx please
thanks i thought you were cuban or
something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you